there's a number of different ways
people use the word scope and first I
want to explore the simplest of them the
first use of the word scope is lexical
scope this usage of the word describes
the regions in your source code where
you can refer to a variable by name
without getting access errors the
specific rules for this version of
scoping can be understood even without
running your code since it only concerns
the areas of your code where different
variable names will have meaning
imagine this file held the source code
for a very simple program in simple
programs with no functions at all there
is exactly one scope which is called the
global scope every variable in such a
program would be stored there we
represent the global scope in these
slides using the color green now in some
JavaScript environments global scope is
shared across different files as a way
for any part of the program to interact
with any other part if we add a variable
to the program that variable is said to
be in the global scope and thus it could
be accessed from anywhere else in your
whole program now we want this program
to help us generate stories that are all
about the same hero so let's put this
hero variable into the global scope
where every other line of code can
reference it also for the sake of this
example we should pretend that there
exists a function called a hero and that
function returns a randomly generated
name we won't be investigating the
source code or the run behavior of that
function during this talk after defining
a variable in a lexical scope you may
make reference to that variable from
anywhere else in that lexical scope
global variables are the easiest since
there's nowhere in your code that you
couldn't access them